for more on john lewis we're joined now
by the chairwoman of the congressional
black caucus
congresswoman karen bass of california
congresswoman good morning
john lewis's passing marks the end of an
era the last of the big six leaders who
planned the march on washington he
wasn't just a civil rights icon but a
multi-generational leader
and legend how do you begin to describe
his legacy
well i will tell you that i have had the
honor for the last 10 years
of serving with him and coming in the
congress and being able to sit in a room
with
a giant like mr lewis and just in my
time
alone i watch tim one make sure that we
have a museum
the african-american history museum i
watched him build a monument to the
enslaved americans
that built the capitol he had
so much influence and was responsible
for
so much incredible change in our country
that his memory will live on but you
know what
on the day of his passing we need to all
recommit to make sure that we continue
to get in good trouble
that we continue to speak out speak up
and
make sure especially today when so much
change is happening it's really our
responsibility to carry his legacy on
now what what i wonder what what he
personally taught you
about how to affect change in washington
i think what he taught me more than
anything was patience
his calm demeanor the fact that everyone
in the house
democrats republicans everyone respected
him
i remember one time when one of my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle
introduced an amendment that was going
to cut funding
around voting rights around enforcement
of voting rights and mr lewis saw it on
tv from his office
he ran down to the floor he gave one of
those
incredible speeches and my colleague on
the other side of the aisle
apologized in public and withdrew that
amendment
that was the power that he had in the
house of representatives
and i had the honor on the 50th
anniversary to walk across that bridge
and i hope to be there again when that
bridge is renamed for him
the nation is seeing what what it looks
like this morning without without john
lewis
but congresswoman have you thought about
what what congress will look like
without john lewis well uh and you know
what we're in session this week
and it'll be a sad week i'm sure that
many of us will be on the floor paying
tribute to mr lewis
that was one thing he used to always say
to me he tried to get me to call him
john
and i told him i said no mr lewis i'm
never calling you john
you're mr lewis to me congresswoman it's
dana jacobson now we were talking with
ambassador
young earlier and he commented on that
loving spirit that really dominated
uh congressman lewis despite all that he
had been through how did you see that
spirit
play out time and time again well i
think we all did and no matter what was
going on in the house
no matter how divisive
it became there was always mr lewis that
would just have that moral authority
that would allow us to uh rise up
above our partisan differences and uh
and i think that's part of his legacy i
think he taught us
how you should go about creating change
when you have differences certainly a
message that a lot of people can look to
now congresswoman karen bass
absolutely thank you very much